when are the nas you have some Nas feet
Feature Feature work yes I do when is
the Nazis yeah I feel like I know I've
been talking about it I've heard the
songs yes you have um because I felt
like two songs right I'm not crazy no no
you crazy it's one it is just one okay
let's not blow it up too much I probably
five songs it was I'm thinking never
mind someone else I know has two now
songs oh I want to know it was it was
belly because with nas in the weekend uh
yeah but you have but you have a great
time my brother belly you have a great
Nas record bro my Nas record is
ridiculous I'm not gonna lie and um
yeah the thing is so I started working
with Sky storage on this whole project
and you know we put some joints out like
you said the one with Jeremiah which was
called King James who's got a it's great
yeah great [ __ ] a lot of love yeah I got
I got synced on ESPN I dropped the one
with French earlier this year yeah la
Habibi got a lot of love those were
really like I put them out to kind of
test the waters but like the album is
done now and and it took a little longer
than I expected that's why I had already
you know I didn't hold it in when I went
in the studio with nas I posted that
[ __ ] the next day yeah and and now we
are here and it's still not out but it's
coming man like now everything is ready
so it's just just incredible tape
dropping in the album and then the album
early next year you know I want to start
rolling out of February drop the album
in March yeah I got some big [ __ ] on
there would you and burner do another
clap album I would love to but you know
it was dope yeah the first one is dope
and I yo almost on a daily basis I have
people in my DM asking what I'm doing
another album with Burner just like I
got a lot of burner fans out of this
tour with them yeah and then I work lot
would be real or just dropped a crazy
Jordan would be real too but also just
you know he embraced me early on before
all of this so that whole scene that
whole crowd is kind of similar you know
I mean yeah
that smoker crowd so they'd be hitting
me all the time of course I would love
to Berner is my dog but you know he's uh
Forbes cover top five richest you know
what I mean like he busy he's gonna be
number one Richard soon yes he is so he
you know he busy so so hopefully but I
would say in the next two years burner's
gonna be richer than D and Jay-Z
yeah I wouldn't be surprised actually
it's going probably 100 yeah it's gonna
happen